seit tagen da hören wir dass wladimir
putins truppen in der ukraine
gerade die nachschubkonvois immer wieder
angegriffen und zerstört werden und
julian jetzt liegt uns ein video vor
eine helmkamera von ukrainischen
soldaten die mal zeigt wie genau diese
hinterhalte funktionieren und wie dieser
angriff auf die russischen truppen genau
vonstatten läuft für uns dadurch ganz
genau was wir hier sehen ist ein video
was uns vorgestern abend erreicht hat es
ist consol aus der provinz oder aus der
region stammen und was wir hier sind
tatsächlich sechs kandidaten drei sind
zu sehen eine kamera auf zwei hinter ihm
die einen russischen panzer angreifen
wir sehen das jetzt hier gerade eine rpg
geschossen wird also eine panzerfaust
ausgeschossen wurde eine ganz alte jetzt
sehen wir auch die die zurückgeblieben
sind und wir sehen gleich noch ein video
dass dann ein panzer brennt ein panzer
der offenbar ganz allein unterwegs war
fand die unterstützung ohne leute die
ihm aus der luft oder aus von monster
abdecken und am ende wird dieser panzer
dann zerstört und die ukraine haben
diese kleine schlacht obwohl sie nur zu
6 sind hier gewonnen unfassbare
aufnahmen muss es noch mal sagen also
die haben jetzt die szene mit dem
brennenden panzer ich drückte man einmal
auf pause und wir markieren das also ich
hier den hat es getroffen die der ja der
steht in flammen nach diesem rpg
beschuss aber um vielleicht noch mal
zurück zu springen also die klinischen
soldaten die haben eben eine kamera
ansicht dran und man kann sozusagen
deren taktisches vorgehen beobachten
kann sehen auch was sie an ausrüstung
dabei haben beeindruckend finde ich mit
welcher ruhe sie vorgehen das ist
hochprofessionell und dann aber eben mit
diesen anti panzer raketen auf diese
stahl monster auf der anderen seite
schießen und die tatsächlich erfolgreich
ausschalten ja also du sagst dass das
hochprofessionell was wir sehen sind
keine wehrpflichtigen oder keine die
grad einberufen wurde sondern das wusste
ich noch erklären das ist eine
sporteinheit eine ukrainische
spezialeinheit der polizei und wir sehen
auch wenn wir uns mal angucken das ist
hier nichts zufall hier ist überhaupt
kein zufall dabei immer einer mit einer
panzerfaust hat einen dabei der entdeckt
mit einer mit maschinengewehr der
nächste auch wird dann sozusagen gedeckt
und wir haben zwei vorne zwei mittig und
zwei bleiben im verborgenen für den fall
dass doch einer von den erwischt wird
durch den sniper oder ähnliches in
scharfschützen würden die ideen heraus
ziehen
wir sehen auch dass der angriff eben
durch die bäume passiert genau von der
seite passiert also wenn man sagt mal
aus 90 grad da ist der panzer am
schwächsten vor ihm ist es gefährlich
weil er schießen kann hinterher weiß man
nie wer noch alles kommt es kann ja sein
dass eine kolonne ist und noch jemand
kommt insofern wie das ukrainische
innenministerium schon vor ein paar
tagen erklärt hatte den partisanen
sozusagen immer aus genau von der von
der seite angreifen die sind absolute
experten und profis machen das so und
man denkt ja immer als laie vielleicht
das im krieg da wird geschrieben da wird
gebrüllt aber man hört hier totale ruhe
bei der einheit weil eben jeder genau
weiß was zu tun ist und was zu machen
ist denn du hast das gesagt die soldaten
die wir da gerade gesehen haben das ist
eine polizeispezialeinheit das muss man
sich mal vorstellen es ist die polizei
die ich hier gegen militär kämpft aber
das eben wahnsinnig gut macht wir haben
mal ein bisschen vorbereitet was das
findet truppe ist wie die ausgestattet
sind also hier mit modernsten
sturmgewehren
ausgerüstete truppe mit erna uniform die
moderner ist als das was die bundeswehr
heute hat und aber hier eben diese rpg 7
die seit jahrzehnten kann man sagen im
einsatz ist und eben gerade auch sehr
erfolgreich und sehr tödlich im einsatz
ist es gibt noch einen anderen konvoi
das video hast du mir geschickt und
gesagt darüber müssen wir reden was was
sehen wir hier würde ja nicht was wir
sehen ist ein nachschub kommen bei der
russischen armee und wie so oft man kann
es nicht glauben hat sechs tanklaster
die alleine geschickt worden ist und
zwar entlang einer bahnstrecke links
sehen wir dass wir eine bahnstrecke lang
nicht auf den großen strafen sondern bis
hinterland in der hoffnung irgendwie den
ukrainischen partizan links oben sehen
wir die bahnsteige machen sie doch
gleich schien ja in ukrainischen
partisan dort zu entgehen und dieser
konvoi hat sich von osten durch die
region cerny hat sich nochmal die
schienen auf beiden seiten und den
zerstörten konvoi in richtung kiew
bewegt er hat es nicht geschafft wir
sehen es ja völlig ungeschützt es sind
einfach nur sechs fahrzeuge ohne jede
unterstützung und die wurden dann von
ukrainischen
partisan oder von panischen einheiten
die dort stationierten
ausgeschaltet hier die gleise da dieser
trampelpfad wurde worauf auch immer die
da unterwegs waren und wie du sagst hier
ist nirgendwo in schutz element nichts
was sozusagen diese tanklaster hätte
stoppen können und wir sagen es ja so
oft wenn diese eher einfachen und
primitiven tanklaster nicht durchkommen
dann bleiben ein paar kilometer weiter
die panzer hat stehen die modernen
kampfmaschinen weil die brauchen den
sprit der hier drin gelagert ist ganz
genau dass es gleich doppelt das problem
zum einen haben wir hier sechs tanks die
nicht ankommen als sechs
benzin tag den ich ankommen zum anderen
aber auch sechs benzintank sie nicht
mehr eingesetzt werden können und die
russische armee hat davon nicht so viele
fans hat sie 100 200 aber wir haben
gesehen den letzten tagen da sind schon
40 50 von verbrannt worden das ganze
sonst nicht täuschen ja die russen sind
immer noch absolut überlegen aber wir
sehen hier immer wieder an solchen
hinter helfen dass die russische führung
teilweise strategien wird über die
wirklich militärexperten nur die die
stunde nutzen können stichwort russische
führung auch auf die wollen wir zu
sprechen kommen dass hier sind generäle
zwei oberste die in den letzten tagen
gefallen sind und wir haben es gehört in
der nacht heute nacht da hat es man muss
das so sagen den nächsten general
erwischt einen top-mann wie kann das
sein wie kann es sein dass so hohe
militärs die russland auf wert die
jahrzehntelange kriegserfahrung haben
die in syrien gekämpft haben in
tschetschenien gibt dass die plötzlich
in diesem krieg fallen wir sehen es galt
eingeblendet wir haben eben auch schon
gehört in einer anmoderation jahr vitali
gerasimov der der generalstabschef der
41 russische armee und stellvertretender
kommandant der ami soll gestorben seien
gestern bei aktiv auch umfasst die
ukraine anders abgefangen durch ein ganz
normales telefonat mit einer normalen
sim karte weil die russen offenbar nicht
die technik haben noch verschlüsselt zu
zu zu zu funken oder wie auch immer das
wurde also wirklich man sieht in dem
telefonat können wir das verschlüsselte
sagen nein das können wir nicht wir
können also sprechen gut dann sage ich
sehr vitali ist tot und das ist
unfassbar du hast gefragt warum das so
ist wir haben diese seltsame strategie
der russen einmal von überall
vorzustoßen das heißt wir haben keine
geeinte freund und einmal so vorzustoßen
dass wir immer wieder werden es gerade
gesehen in hinterhalte laufen also immer
wieder denkt man das ist die spitze
dabei ist das schon irgendwie mitten im
tross trainer oder mitten in diesem
angriffs konvoi drin und irgendwo müssen
ja die general neuere und die oberste
auch eben sein die können nicht alle in
russland bleiben sondern sie müssen ihre
truppen kommandieren das heißt wir haben
jetzt nicht die absolute führung der
russischen armee aber leute die sagen
wir mal über 1000 oder 1000 mann ein
kommando haben die müssen irgendwann
rein und wenn es keine geeinte front
gibt dann werden auch sie opfer der
ukrainischen hinterhalt andere experten
die sagen auch dass die militärführung
also ein generalmajor viel höher geht es
ja gar nicht im militärdienst geraden
dass der dass die nach vorne geschickt
werden um die moral der truppe ein stück
weit zu erhöhen also eigentlich sehr
viel weiter hinten in der reihe sind
aber weil die russen sich so schwer tun
in diesem land zu kämpfen auch
vielleicht viele soldaten gar nicht
wissen was sie da tun dass man die
führung eben nach vorne bringt um klar
zu machen hier sind eure obersten
generäle und darum geht es was dann
natürlich ist sehr viel gefährlicher
macht für diese männer wer auch
gefährlich ist julian über die wollen
wir auch sprechen dass sind diese männer
hier der tschetschenen konvoi der auf
dem weg nach kiew ist gehören die ganze
tage schon von diesen männern einmal von
dir die analyse wer wer ist das hier und
warum sind diese männer so gefährlich
also was wir hier haben sind spezial
anhalten des tschetschenen machthabers
mann ist am samstag in ist man teil von
russland aktuell kadyrow und das sind
seine leute das sind die
spezialeinheiten aus tschetschenien und
du hast du schon gesagt die gehören zu
den brutalsten zu den gnadenlosen aber
auch zu den effektivsten einheiten der
russischen armee kann das sind leute die
quasi immer kampferfahrung haben die
also auch im süden gegen regen gegen
aufständische kämpfen wir hören uns auch
hier sogar diesen untertitel vielleicht
sieht man sich im untertitel auf
wichtige regel nicht mal russischer
sondern das ist ein tschetschenischer so
eine art von arabisch also man hört
einige worte raus einige worte zum
russischen die sind nördlich von kiew
sind wirklich die besten einheiten die
sie haben und die sollen wohl den den
angriff auch auf tiere oder die
umzingelung von kiew aktuell leiten wie
viele männer sind das etwa wie groß ist
dieser konvoi also rede von 20 von 200
von 2000 also wir sehen schon außen
herum die die faust auf den auto sehr
leicht und das sind alles spezial
gehalten das heißt wir haben ja keine
alten laster wir haben hier keine 50
jahre alten panzer sondern wir haben
hier aus den letzten zehn jahren gebaute
einheiten oder oder spezialfahrzeuge der
russischen armee was besseres kann hier
nicht diesen am mobilsten die haben da
oben teilweise auch elektrische
maschinengewehr auf oder eben das was
man auch von den amerikanern kennt das
duo das genau das erinnert sehr an
nato-truppen ausrüstung auch nochmal
hier guckt die helme
modernste ballistische helm gehörschutz
mit mit funkgerät so sind nato truppen
im einsatz
das allein das ist schon beängstigend
das ist es und dazu ist es eben ihre
reputation man weiß also da wo die
reinkommen da wächst kein gras mehr also
dass die machen alles kaputt und tod was
ihnen im wege steht und sind dabei
absolut gnadenlos aber man muss ihm
sagen aus russischer sicht auch das
genau wahrscheinlich was man braucht um
auf 4 vorzustossen denn da sind ja auch
die besten lokalen einheiten aktuell du
sprichst es an der vorstoß aus kiew
abschließend können wir einschätzen wo
sich dieser tschetschenen konvoi aktuell
befindet wie weit ist dennoch weg von
kiew also netterweise hat sie mal für
uns eingesetzt nämlich unsere arbeit
sondern sie wurden sozusagen die
lokalisierte verortet wo sie sich
befinden dass es ungefähr 35 km nördlich
von kiew kann sich auf der medica oder
die ukraine karte dann kannst du uns
zeigen wo etwa wir uns befinden versucht
es nochmal also wir befinden uns also
quasi auf halben weg zwischen
tschernobyl und kiew angel wurde dieses
aufgenommen und wir wissen heute genau
wir wissen leider heute dass das die
weiter vorrücken dass sie nicht auch auf
tiere sondern auch an tierversuchen
vorbeizukommen wenn die richtung um in
diesen belagerungsring zu schließen das
video ist ungefähr zwei tage alten sie
können heute schon 50 kilometer weiter
sein und ich befürchte 50 kilometer
näher an kraft düstere aussichten julian
vielen vielen dank wie immer für eine
analyse seiner expertise